viele menschen würden am liebsten nie
wieder kochen oder einkaufen müssen
und ich muss gestehen ich gehöre dazu
seit dem starken anwuchs an
lieferdiensten gerade deutschlands
großstädten rückt dieser teure wunsch
immer mehr in greifbare nähe
diese woche erfülle ich mir diesen
wunsch die kein einziges mal einkaufen
und werden noch nicht mal das simpelste
aller gerichte zubereiten sondern wäre
jede einzelne mahlzeit beim
lieferservice bestellen anschließend
bewerte ich die einst an die verdienste
und zeigt am ende
ich bin geld ich für diese sieben tage
hinblättern muss dieses video wird mal
wieder von mir selbst unterstützt in der
video beschreibung findet ihr den
trailer zu einem schnittkurs mit dem man
schnell alles lernen was man für einen
schnitt von musikvideos urlaubsvideos
oder youtube-videos braucht das sammeln
von zutaten und deren verarbeitung zu
essen ist seit jeher ein existenzielles
element des menschlichen daseins schon
immer hat der kampf um nahrung auch wenn
er sich mittlerweile zu einkaufen und
kochen entwickelt hat menschen aller
kulturen zusammen geschweißt und
buchstäblich an einen tisch gebracht an
einen tisch gebracht und ganze
zivilisation geprägt gar keinen bock auf
zivilisationen etwas bestellen ja
einzahlen muss also ich weiß nicht ob
das blödes jetzt schon zu sagen dass das
das billigste experiment überhaupt wird
aber ich wüsste nicht was noch
schwieriger wird jetzt habe ich
natürlich fall der wahl was ich essen
möchte ich glaube ich starte mal die
woche mit irgendwas gesunden unternehmen
wie reis mit gemüse bestellt dann kann
ich mich ja jetzt zurücklehnen
das essen war jetzt wirklich mega
schnell da ich meine es kann schon mal
normal so bis zu einer stunde dauern
manchmal sogar auch länger aber jetzt 15
20 minuten wo ich wiederum nicht weiß
wie es gemacht wurde aber ich beschwere
mich natürlich auch nicht ich habe das
hier natürlich schon mal gestellt sogar
auch schon in einem anderen video
ich weiß was du kriegen wird und das ist
echt ziemlich geil dass ich nichts
kommen muss und auch ziemlich gesund
natürlich ist es ultra teuer aber das
rechtfertige ich jetzt einfach mal in
dieser woche damit dass sich parallel
noch ein zweites video dreh und zwar die
anderen stunden arbeitswoche und da habe
ich natürlich wirklich keine zeit jetzt
jeden tag eine halbe stunde oder sogar
eine stunde zu gucken und aufzuräumen
dementsprechend auch wenn bestellen
deutlich weniger zeit kostet als selbst
zu gucken dauert es trotzdem immer fünf
bis zehn minuten bis man etwas gefunden
hat am schnellsten glaube ich wäre es
sich einfach eben etwas auf dem brot zu
klatschen aber dass wir auf dauer
bestimmt nicht so lecker wie bestellen
sonntagmittag schon gut gehen lassen
haben würde ich mal sagen ist heute ein
bisschen italienisch eine reihe so viel
was weißt du ne lasagne jetzt pro mu
weil ich weiß dass die lieferdienste
morgen es uns heute 30 aufmachen werden
konnte ich mir jetzt auch schon
frühstück und was gibt's besseres zum
frühstücken als eine richtig kalte pizza
dieser teurer als die lasagne und
bestellen 22 euro kostet der spaß
und es dauert 40 minuten locker leben
ich würde sagen das ist frühstück
tendenziell werden werden natürlich
nicht
[Musik]
jetzt geht's ans bewerten unsere erste
mahlzeit war wird ferner die war
ziemlich lustig also lieferung sowie so
etwa nach 20 minuten ist man stark und
das essen auch fünf sternen da ich auch
hier schon extra bestellt oft ja das
nächste ist war von diesem italiener das
war auch richtig geil
tanja diese lasagne und diese pizza
gegessen die haben aber auch keine
rechnung gestellt also liebe pizzeria
wenn ihr das jetzt tun also ich hab kein
geld gekriegt von mir ich es ja gerade
schon wieder meine pizza frühstück via
und werde ich jetzt nicht verrückt muss
ich mir einfach schon gedanken machen
was ich als nächstes gestellt das ist
einfach es ist stressig
ich bin mal gespannt wie viel ich in der
woche zudem werde ich sag ich mal wiegen
aber ich glaube ich werde ein bisschen
gesünder wieder es nichts die tage
danach haben so viel und ich bei hans im
glück diese leckeren salate und brote
bestellt hat hier vier sterne 4 sterne
ist kann ich mal so krass
hier scheint es gar nicht mal so gut
tatsächlich bin echt stark also essen
war immer perfekt bemerkung fans
es ist nach tag 2 aber streng genommen
schon tag 3 denn ich arbeite gerade bei
6 uhr morgens durch und können wir
gerade noch einen kleinen
mitternachtssnack mein frühstück habe
ich habe mir mal frech wie ich bin ins
meeting eingequetscht der fans nicht der
älteste trecker buch essen beim meeting
spart einfach schön viel zeit danach
noch schön so viele leute was soll ich
sagen ich habe es mir gut gehen lassen
und ist das nicht eine schöne
kameraeinstellung wie diese ganzen
zuschießt nacheinander weg verschwinden
ich bin schon loriot war super und das
war lecker da würde ich jetzt gerade
richtig bock nochmal dazu erste cover
vom sterne haben sie sich verdient von
mir gibt's das ist definitiv 5er
anmerkung geiler schmaus mich ist das
haus also der wert kann aber auch
richtig leckeres mahl bestellt wir haben
davor noch nie so stück bestellt aber
die sind auch richtig geil gewesen das
richtig essen fünf sterne definitiv die
führung auf 5 sterne kann man nichts
sagen das ist noch warm angekommen war
auch weil es günstig wie viel geld wir
da gelassen moment
ja 36 euro wenn man also ich weiß nicht
mal wieder dieses da war nix übrig da
war überhaupt nichts übrig ich habs auf
video wo jedes einzeln dieser sozis
weggesteckt wurde und ich habe am ende
noch so richtig gierig auf steins
geguckt ich schwöre euch ja man
einblenden
das essen ist da ich weiß gar nicht
welche tag wollte eigentlich ist im
experiment normale dass er immer recht
gut im auge weil ich halt einfach fast
froh bin wenn experiment vorbei ist aber
bei dem hier können wir euch daran
gewöhnen außer an die kosten weil die
sind schon echt krass das ist jetzt kein
riesenproblem für mich wäre nicht
pleitegehen keine sorgen aber würde
trotzdem war nicht bruder noch nicht
ganz schon fast nicht so richtig
genießen einfach weil es richtig teuer
ist klemme partner
wir wollten gestern auch essen gehen die
werben so richtig freude müssen
angefangen zu erstellen weil die reise
eine bionade
wir haben etliche bestellt das aber wohl
um das ist einfach fresh daten dann
bleibt er war auch richtig geil da waren
so richtig rohkost sachen drauf weiß
nicht ich weiß nicht ob ich vier sterne
geben soll das ist druck aber ich gehe
mal vier sterne es sich gerne dafür gibt
stern war diese zahl zeigt dieses
indische ding war ziemlich lecker essen
war tag sorgt dafür dass ich es mag
frühstück ist ist jetzt fünf uhr morgens
ich habe gerade das heißt also früchte
geholt weil sie gestern bestellt hat ich
habe selten morgens hunger aber
letztlich kann so richtig schön beispiel
so geht's zu freddy also stöhr waffel
und seinem kopf vor meinen lieblings
ersten kommen
darauf freue ich mich schon die ganze
woche aber wir dürfen jetzt nicht die
zeit gibt ja im grunde früh aufgestanden
bin deswegen metzger hätte ich alle
essens gehälter von dieser woche auf
einen haufen gelegt würden wir
wahrscheinlich einen riesenberg müll
sehen wobei man fairerweise sagen muss
hätte ich alle zutaten in supermarkt
gekauft wäre dabei vielleicht sogar noch
mehr müll entstanden weil restaurants
sehr deutlich größere packungen von
allen zutaten kaufen und dadurch normal
weniger müll pro portion essen erzeugen
sollten als jemand der für sich selbst
kommt für frei ließ koch vormals bei dem
wir uns gerade seht habe ich übrigens
auch die einzige ausnahme im video
gemacht denn ich musste das was wir
schauen natürlich auch probieren und
anschließend haben wir auch bei ihm eine
pizza bestellt ich hab's ein bisschen
versammelt und zwar jetzt schon 22 40
und die ganze lieferdienste machen
irgendwie um 11 meisten schon zu ja ich
hab ein bisschen essen im kühlschrank
aber das wird mir vielleicht heute abend
reichen aber nicht für morgen früh und
da ist das wichtigste
von der penne arrabiata die bowling die
war richtig stark kann man nichts
guckt euch einfach an superlecker die
pizza kann ich leider auch nicht
bewerten ja habe ja nicht ich bestellt
danke moore auf jeden fall war ein
bisschen enttäuscht dafür dass es hier
ein lieferdienst wieder über habe ich
echt wenig wo die pizzen gegessen
die erste pizza die war okay ging um die
welt es war okay die nudeln werden
warmgemacht kommentare gelesen und ein
kurz gesagt video angeschaut
leider war friedrichs video nicht das
einzige koch video hin dass ich
eingeladen wurde und so musste ich noch
eine kleine ausnahme für das video von
sophie machen und zwar darf der thomas
heute aussuchen mit welchen zutaten ich
heute kochen
[Musik]
link dazu findet ihr eine video
beschreibung jetzt aber weiter zu den
nudeln hier die noten muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen dass ich die nicht so
krass finden gibt zum ersten mal ein wo
nur drei sterne es tut mir richtig leid
die waren okay
sehe ich so jetzt alle letzte tag meines
bestellen sie heute werde zum
allerletzten mal was bei berlins
bestellen gut jetzt nicht mehr immer
nicht wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich noch
mal eben das geschäft ich blicke
sentimentale zurück auf die
ereignisreiche woche haben wir übrigens
wieder zwei maps bestellt von da wo ich
schon mal netz gestellt habe ich nämlich
neues habe ich noch mal bestellt sophie
und sebastian haben gerade schon
bestellt ich dachte mir es aussuchen
abend in delhi speziell des hauses wo er
geschnitzt ist
lieferkosten 1 euro das ja cool
bestellen
lafraise haben wir schon mal gestellt
wir haben fünf sterne haben erst drei
wochen insgesamt bisschen alle davon
wissen es ich gerne dafür gibt's zu
vielen stellen
ich habe der zahl bestellten das
eigentlich sollte ich mir nicht
irgendein soll ich mein ich gehe jetzt
mal fünf sterne anmerkungen jo perfekt
gut das hat zu viel bestellt in diesem
sinne kann ich es auch nicht bewerten
auf jeden fall da kann man nichts sagen
also dass gruppe b war richtig geil ich
kann mich daran ändern dass sie am ende
sogar noch ein bisschen hunger hatte
aber alles in allem war es richtig geil
okay der moment der wahrheit wie viel
geld habe ich jetzt verschwendet nur für
dummes essen wir sehen hier diese
übersicht also ich hab ja sager gestellt
wir rechnen dass jetzt mal alles
zusammen 260 euro für nur eine woche das
heißt würde ich auf dem monat erstrecken
würde ich es einfach auf 1.000 euro
belaufen und das ist natürlich absolut
und sparsamkeit es war echt böse aber
jetzt weiß ich wenn ich nie wieder
kochen wollen würde muss ich die 1000
euro im monat für essen locker haben
dafür hat sich doch dieses extremen
lehrreiche experimente schon mal gelohnt
alles in allem war das ein experiment
das ich gerne weiterführen würde zu
fahren da nicht die hohen kosten werden
und wenn ich nicht gerade ausschließlich
lieferdienst essen essen dürfte bei
meiner zwischendrin dann doch mal lust
auf obst oder nüsse oder sonstige snacks
und wenn man abends vergisst sich
frühstück für den nächsten tag mehr zu
bestellen dann ist es auch nicht schlimm
man muss eben immer seinen tag um das
bestellen herum planen und da bin ich
wirklich froh das ist vorbei ich muss an
dieser stelle wieder werbung für einen
schnittkurs machen check den linke der
video beschreibung aus wenn hier
schneiden werden möchte talent ihr alles
innerhalb kürzester zeit wie youtube
videos für musikvideos für urlaub videos
link in der beschreibung und wenn er
mich hat diese reise begleiten bis jetzt
dann abonniert gerne diesen kanal und
folgt auf instagram man dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]